classic action-movie fabulous all right
sounds good I think we can handle that
to show the house all right so I will
say I've played this a couple of times
already so I sort of know what to expect
and hopefully one crash but so where are
we exactly explain where we are the
whole first one you see here is fortune
Valley this is a most most diverse
open-world that we've ever built for
nature it's got a massive city called
silver rock with tons a different
districts where you can explore and
racing game pretty close across the
mountains to great you know drifting
events and took the hill climbs got the
canyons and again this is a place no
pepper valley okay funny
Todd likes and thirsty just look like a
perfect setting for an action movie
heist like the one you're about to do so
one of the things that's already really
cool is that I can just drive off-road
you're no longer confined completely to
the road that's right it's the most open
and you just be an experience with
overbilled so you can find your own path
I mean we've got the checkpoints in this
mission to lead your strengths of that
truck but now when you're free roaming
you can go off-road you can explore this
world
the fire cool so what's going on here
there's the truck we got to take that
River point you got a crew you're
meeting another wing for this truck it's
carrying the two million dollar
Koenigsegg it's going whizzed past here
and then Tyler and Jess are gonna hop
into action here then I walked up to
their Mustang RTR all right yeah classic
me interest being right here right so
what's the what's the plan what are we
planning to do yeah so today I take the
wheels can't use this street racing
skills to carve his way through dense
traffic he's gonna deal with some some a
our rivals are gonna protect the cargo
but most importantly he's gonna drive
against that truck but Jess can get into
position to hijack this truck in motion
all right sounds good let's get going to
catch up with this truck see what you
can do Nick all right so I've got
nitrous
an actress punch if you're gonna try to
catch up to be rivals
okay pal yeah let's go we've got health
on Tahoe there was a quick takedown
cousin out you laid down you are a
natural
oh yeah I saw a doctor's rifle we've got
these cameras that percent your biggest
baddest crushers in the game
let's get ripped in the truck the plan
is to catch up to the truck by the
tongue because in the tunnel any air
surveillance I'm not going to be able to
see this hijacking motion so you got to
take take take this truck down in the
tunnel so one thing I think we should
talk about really quickly is just the
way the game feels mm-hmm could you
mention that of it yeah we provide
yourselves on having heroic rocking
physics that are really heck of a play
so anyone can pick up the controller
they they're hopping this Mustang
they're going 150 miles an hour and they
feel like a hero right away
so we caught up to the truck and things
never got a plan yeah now movies here
things got a sideways so you know the
truck driver really doesn't want your
steel legs ache sorry he's brake jockey
the doors are flying open hey your
setback
he's just start booking it right now
these plow through always traffic are
making life talks tough for you you got
a navigate your way through the scenes
we can catch up to that truck he's made
an absolute mess of this I want all
right so I'm pushing all right
you can catch Herman
I'll go address
any more nitrous new though here we have
some enforcers so now you know talking
about that the AI impervious remain so a
lot of the fans are asking for tougher
AI here so it when they catch up to
opponents they're really jostling and
battling with them every overtake is
burned so these guys have ramped up
their their attitude to 11 right so when
you shut them they're gonna fight back
so Erica I make life easy for you now
yeah they get you pretty hard
what's cool is as you you learn the
world you finds different things in the
environment that you can use against
your rivals to looking for for telephone
poles Gabrielle's traffic cars more
convenient traffic jam free a use there
you know can you turn against the other
one right away gonna bounce off to here
we go
almost you see pretty nasty they are
tough credit got three to go
that's really cool is the best way I
kind of think now is to crash into
things in the environment like using
those tolls still hard but absolutely
exception in a open world game you're
gonna find ways that you want to go
through replay over and over you're
gonna find different ways to take down
these forces which attacks life
trying to deal with their top man
always only to left Nick the truck is
getting away man you want that car
there's no way this trucks getting away
oh that was a movie moment if I ever saw
one
alright let's get rid of this guy
alright you go again we play up you know
these action movie moments right when
you have these big big tape crashes
we're gonna present it to you I'm gonna
I'm gonna wait up for this guy so I can
crash him out
oh he's gonna come charge here look out
there we bury autumn just like you
planned it Nick yeah fun percent on
forget that fillers all right no
punching you gotta catch it from the
truck plantain went sideways so we're
gonna go to plan B we gotta catch up to
this track was gonna hijack it before
that truck hits the ceilings cuz there's
some serious hit on you but you gotta
get to that truck and get that class a
fight every day I'm quitting from City
it's coming pushing hard burger truck
drivers go into oncoming making your
life difficult got a weave through that
are coming traffic turn down a gap there
we go
line it up for guests come on there we
go here's just this big big moment
with three dreadful characters we have
interaction missions of these dynamic
vehicle switches so you were playing
this time of a street racer
now you gotta jump into the Koenigsegg
and drive this guess switching
characters I like it and there you go
you got it you've done this before
you've stolen a two million dollar car
before all the time yeah yeah alright so
now I go to steal that sense of speed in
this awesome hyper car this goes fast to
generate some heat
in this mission so look out here you've
got the cupcakes we play this the
highway height when payback comes out
November 10th you're gonna have to use
Jess to take out cops avoid rhinos avoid
spike strips roadblocks all the intense
cop case action that you expect from me
for speed cool so what else can you tell
me about the story really briefly mm-hmm
so we we've structured the game such
that you're playing three characters
they all have their own quest lines it
all comes together them getting revenge
against the house cool so should we jump
into some customization and do let's see
we can do with some of these cars in
this crazy crazy world oh yes a
customization right how markers have
been talking about it in the live show
it's back we're not gonna do anything
out of the ordinary yeah maybe we will I
thought maybe maybe we got some cool
stuff yeah this is bring the vehicle
director people out the vehicle art
director there we go
so you know these cars inside and out
yes I lived and breathed them for the
last couple of years all right so we're
gonna do some customization obviously
customizations huge for Need for Speed
ease and it's back it's back and it's
bigger it's bigger I'm Bethany yeah so I
think we'll try and boot into the into
the garage and then we'll see what cars
we've got on offer yeah so just briefly
we should talk about the garage it's yes
yeah so the garage we've got space for
five cars in our garage but this time
around we have got a virtual warehouse
so that allows us to effectively give
you limitless cars so you can bring them
in and out of your garage and you know
work with the cars that you want to work
with all so you can do just as many as
you want absolutely all right so let's
talk about some of these cars so we've
got the BMW m4 we had the m4 in the last
game but this time we've upgraded we've
gone from the GTS so it's a bit more
track orientated it's a bit more bit
more performance Orion okay we got some
muscle as well we've got some muscle
cars so last time around we didn't
really hit the money on on the muscle
cars so
yeah we we've done a bit more this time
right and yes when this and 350 said
right so everybody's been asking for it
we can't deny the fans what they want so
we've put it in need for speed awesome
and this one yeah they look cookie right
it seems a bit out of place in need for
speed but what we've done is we've built
this teacher called the derelict set
again Marcus touched upon it in the in
the live show but what the devil it is
is a way for us to kind of let the
player explore the open world that we've
got it's a rich open open world that we
have so we put these cars out there in
the world for you to find and explore
and kind of take them back to your
garage and find all the parts that you
need to build them cool so effectively
it takes a car from stock to scrap let's
scrap to stock your supercar
cool so let's jump in the beetle and fix
it up a bit
yes absolutely so he's looking a bit
rundown right now right yeah we want to
restore it back to stuff yeah now we
should probably say as well these
derelicts you don't need to restore them
like this you can only upgrade them a
little bit I think we'll show that in a
little bit
absolutely and you could leave it like
this if you wanted to yeah for sure not
my particular style but you know what I
mean it might be somebody so yeah you
can see some of them more of the part so
you're looking pretty good
absolutely so we've tried to make sure
that we've got party and every
interaction point that we have that we
have for this car we want to make sure
that we've got a rich experience
wherever you go on the car we've
designed a lot of parts for this car as
well because you know out there in the
reality there's not that much thing I
can do to a beetle but this is need for
speed right and we want to take it that
extra separate of course of course so we
can play around with this car let's talk
about some of the brands there are also
a Need for Speed payback yeah so we've
not ditched any of the brands that we
had previously so we've we've come back
and we've got the your rocket ponies
we've got your Liberty walks you've got
your vortex party for APR parts we've
got all these rims that you can see any
rims so we all we love that stuff we
want to bring that back to the people
of course so I think we've done a pretty
good job of showing this off shall we
show off the big big thing yeah so I
talked about it previously we want to
take these cars to supercars right so
here we are we've we've got our super
builds so these are effectively the
biggest the baddest the most performance
orientated cars that you can build and
need for speed yeah I've got my personal
favourite down at the bottom on
throatily off-road off-road it's off
roads back in into need for speed and
that is crazy we wanted to build
something special yeah
what's more special than to show a
jacked up people awesome so what what do
these do we should say that these are
derelict things specific parts so yeah
they're really cause that you find in
the world will be the only ones that we
can take to the Super build we want to
make sure that those cars are special
and you want to put some time into them
and um put the effort into making them
the Super Bowls right of course
now just while we have some extra time
let's talk about some of the stance
tuning and stuff like that stance tuning
is back again and so what we've done
this time around is take them slightly
right we wanted to make sure that we
could slam a car on the day of course
love-crazy camber so why not go even
further than we did before looks crazy
it's a bit of an odd combination that
you've got there's a bit SoCal on a
rusty here we go there we go yeah so the
last predator the rapid is back we're
not gonna go into the detail of it right
now because you know it would take you
days maybe yeah it works so I think
that's been a pretty good first look at
Need for Speed payback
any last words from you guys yeah
everything you love about Need for Speed
cause action driving blockbuster
missions November 10th check out to you
for Speed payback alright so thanks for
checking out Need for Speed payback
we'll throw it to Madden with the long
shot trailer